let's do a draft of the defensive
players that we would start a franchise
with it's always the quarterback it's
always the offense
we're starting a franchise with a
defensive player who is it going to be
chris i you know i was offered the first
pick during the break but i'm gonna go
ahead and let you have it you get the
first pick three rounds let's go well
you know i'm you know this is this is an
obvious one you know that's why i almost
feel like bad that i'm taking it but i'm
still gonna go with aaron donald here
he's still gonna be the first guy right
now in the nfl where if i'm starting a
franchise and i need to pick one
defensive player you know the only thing
i would say is okay maybe he's you know
he's at the the very peak of his career
right now and probably going to start to
come downhill just a little bit if i had
to be fair but this guy with tremendous
work ethic we know we've seen him in
person and to me you know probably
should have still been the defensive
player of the year last year i mean he
was the best defensive player in the
game gilmore of course was phenomenal
and deserved uh his award i don't want
to say anything like that but i i'm
still going with aaron donald at this
point in time
yeah look here's the thing aaron donald
is 29 i know and and that was surprising
to me to see how old he is but he was
drafted in 2014 right he was drafted
later than he should have been but he's
29 at some point when you consider all
of that pounding that he takes there is
going to be
just the commencement of of a of a slide
yeah in the skill set you can't continue
at that level into your mid-30s i know
we've we've allowed ourselves to think
that because quarterbacks are doing it
other great players are going to do it
no that's not how it works so
uh i wouldn't have taken aaron oh you
wouldn't
i i know i because i'm starting a
franchise i'm going to be around for a
while i want my defensive player with
which i start the franchise to be around
for a while too and when you look at
what nick bosa did last year for the
49ers when you look at how he elevated
that entire defense how his presence and
his the inability to contain nick bosa
opened up the rest of that defensive
line i don't want to take anything away
from d ford and the rest of nick's
teammates but i think nick bosal was the
difference there not d ford nick bose is
the guy that changed that defense and uh
if i'm starting a franchise i want the
guy who's in his second year who's got
multiple defensive player of the year
awards in front of him not behind well
just because my guy might still have a
lot in front of him too don't don't
don't crap on my guy when you don't know
the future okay
be careful that your guy's got an injury
history mine doesn't all right so let's
just just i just wanted to give a little
pushback but i'm very much real in in
like cahoots with you here i agree with
you nick bosa would have definitely been
one of my top three picks here for sure
and i agree with you what your statement
was with the 49ers this was the best
player
maybe on their football team last year
certainly on their defense for my money
and i don't even like it's not that's
just my opinion but i just know just
from people i talked to during the
season last year after the season was
over when they played the 49ers nick
bosa was candidate number one of oh he's
amazing against the run he's of course a
great pass rusher he was the guy that
teams were worried about more than
anybody and i think that speaks a lot to
you know him as a player all right i'm
gonna go with the guy that we're the
reason we're having the segment you know
i'm going with miles garrett i am i mean
he is i think just starting the prime of
his career right now and he is just like
you talked about with nick bosa except i
think i could sit here and argue maybe
he's more of a
physical dominant presence even the nick
boson that's saying a lot i mean these
are guys who are superstar players but
miles garrett to me the same way game
changer you always have to account for
who he is even if you have a really
awesome franchise left tackle you know a
lot of them they're gonna they're gonna
you're gonna have to help them out every
now and then and miles garrett is more
than a pass rusher he's great against
the run and i think really he's just
starting to hit the tip of the iceberg
here for what he can be as a player and
as a man as everything so
i am going with miles garrett again i
know i picked him as nfl defensive
player of the year last year uh i think
he's probably going to be my pick for
the guy i'll go with again this year
when we do do that
and he's he's on the younger side than
your other pick so that's good i mean i
am skewing for the guys i hear you are
going to be around right and and garrett
fits that mold better than donald but i
got one that you're going to like and
this is probably the guy that was going
to be your third round pick so i i'm i'm
stealing him from you before you can i
want derwin james
safety
yeah
i got a big star next to his name right
now
yeah yeah i want darwin james baby um uh
and and we haven't seen it yet because
he was injured last year we got a flash
of it as a rookie yeah remember he
inexplicably fell down the board on
draft day in in 2018 and uh i i feel
like
i feel like the bomb is gonna go off for
him this year and and he's gonna become
a guy that we're talking about all the
time yeah i feel like this is the year
that that happens and in hindsight yeah
anyone's gonna say boy i wish i had that
guy on my team no no doubt about it i i
think he is you know yeah we didn't get
to see him a lot last year he came back
late in the year and was not totally
back and hitting on all cylinders but
the rookie year you know you said it
right mike his rookie year he was
already one of the best safeties in
football definitely was and and i i can
i could i know you know he fell down the
draft board but to number 18 like you
said i know there was a handful of teams
in front of them or in front of the
chargers who thought derwent and had
derwin james as a top five top ten
player in the draft but as we know it's
about need and everything like that and
it just happened to be one of those
years um so i'm with you hey i'm staying
at the same position all right yeah my
guy's a little bit more of a pain in the
butt all right he likes to talk a little
bit more than derwyn james but i'm going
with jamal adams who i do think is the
best safety in football now this is my
organization this is my franchise i
think i can coach them all adams to be
that right guy in the locker room just
like all coaches think they can fix
every player but to me you know just
so phenomenal in so many different
aspects around the line of scrimmage
whether it's taking on blockers making
tacklers great blitzer great sideline to
sideline jamal adams is the best safety
in the game for me right now i'll i'll
go with him it's a tough one there
yeah i uh
i and and look i i still am fascinated
to see how this plays out i know for
jamal adams in the new york jets i think
he's going to show up i think he
realizes this is not the year to be
trying to force a trade this is not the
year to be trying to force a new
contract all right who are you going to
go with here who are you going to go
like let me hear your list who's you're
down to who you down to in your finals
here i saved i saved the best for last
not the best but i saved a guy that you
weren't going to take because you can't
pronounce his name danielle hunter still
only 25 years old 25 years old he's got
54 and a half sacks he had more sacks
than anyone who's ever played the game
before he turned 25 he is quiet he
doesn't go out seeking attention there
are plenty of other big personalities on
that team that we talk about and that we
think about but he is dominant and i'm
starting a team i want him on one i'll
take nick bose on one side and i'll take
the neil hunter on the other side and
the quarterback isn't going to have time
to to to make his first read let alone
his second or third read with those two
guys coming after yeah well listen i i
like danielle hunter a lot and you know
it's good that you're sure you got it
right yeah got it right
i'm glad you showed your viking pride i
don't he was on my list i don't think i
would have picked him i think i would
have gone a guy like maybe chris jones
or even tj watt in front of him but uh i
understand it and you you know you bleed
purple you're all about the vikings so i
totally get it
i i actually i mainly wanted to give you
a hard time because
other than today you have been unable to
say daniel hunter's first
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports